Why Nana, what giant nose you have!
Why Pop-pop, what giant ears you have!
Are there parts of your body that never stop
growing?
Hey there irregular growths, Trace here for
DNews!
If today is your 21st birthday, then I’ve
got some bad news for you -- have a drink.
Chances are that if you’re like most of
the population, you’ve stopped growing in
the last few years.
Maybe even the last few months, if you’re
a male, because females undergo puberty earlier,
and subsequently reach the end of their development
a few years before males do.
When I say development, I don’t just mean
puberty, I mean all the development you’ve
gone through starting as a single-celled zygote,
and ending around age 21.
Now, to be clear, you don't actually stop
growing.
You probably have between 50 and 75 trillion
cells in your body at any one time, and each
of those has a limited lifespan, and will
almost certainly be replaced by a new cell,
unless it's a neuron in your brain; those
don’t regenerate on their own.
Of course, your hair and nails keep growing
right up until you die, and by the way, your
hair and nails don’t continue growing after
death, as is the popular urban legend.
No actually, your SKIN shrinks when you die
thanks to dehydration, and it only looks like
things are growing.
Ok, so by now it sounds like you really do
stop growing at the end of the puberty train,
but what’s the BIGGEST difference between
an adult man and an old man.
Take a look at this picture.
You might notice two… or I guess, three
big differences.
The schnozz and the two catcher’s mitts.
The nose and the ears.
They are noticeably larger on older people.
So do your nose and ears really keep growing
forever?
Would immortality mean that we all end up
looking like a giant Elephant person, trunk
included?
Well, the nose and the ears are made up of
something called “cartilage”.
Cartilage is a type of tissue; and your body
has four kinds: connective, epithelial, muscular,
and nervous tissue.
That covers pretty much everything from skin
to the stuff between your bones, to your muscles
and nerves.
Each kind of tissue is unique.
Cartilage is called “connective” tissue
which is the most abundant kind in your body
. That’s because cartilage is basically
like multi-purpose lubricant, glue, and duct
tape all in one.
Cartilage can be worn down, stretched out,
serve as padding for things like your ribs,
the ends of your bones, and your spinal vertebrae,
as well as construct things outside of your
body.
Specifically, the nose and the ears, which
are made up of elastic cartilage.
And cartilage is special; it doesn’t have
blood vessels or nerves in it, which gives
it some interesting properties.
For one, when the tissue starts to break down,
and needs to repair itself… it can’t.
At least, not as easily or cleanly as the
rest of your tissue.
Instead, cartilage ends up healing by scarring.
The formerly elastic structure ends up harder,
and thicker, and droopier, especially as you
age17,.
It's not that cartilage keeps growing as you
get old; it's that it breaks down, sags, drips,
and noticeably enlarges when compared to the
more repairable skin of your face, lips, eyes,
and forehead.
Those stay more or less tight while your ears
and nose slowly but surely succumb to entropy
and gravity.
So, yes.
Parts of the body do get larger in adulthood,
by comparison, like the ears and nose, and
some parts never stop growing while you’re
alive, like your hair and nails.
But, if it’s your 21st birthday, then you’re
almost done developing and you’re stuck
this way…
well for a while.
Which makes sense from an evolutionary standpoint;
after puberty you’re ready to make a baby,
and once you're ready to make a baby, your
genetic structure basically gives up on trying
to make you better.
You might even get smaller.
Sorry big-nosed shorties.
But what if you want to build muscle mass.
Are you actually growing the muscle?
How does that work?
Amy has the answer for you right here.
So what are you the most afraid about in terms
of aging?
Let us know down in the comments, make sure
you come back here every day for more DNews
and please subscribe.